and welcome to the studio it seemed that
your position it had some danger but you
held it what seemed very easily
uh
well perhaps uh
i think i
you know played this game you know far
from excellence
uh like no no not anything close but as
far as i know this line is uh i mean
supposed to be slightly better but in
fact it's more or less a fortress
uh it might be okay i mixed up something
but uh
this probably won't you know the fact i
play badly it doesn't change the you
know the revelation of the whole line
yeah so even i with my like quite poor
play managed to to call the draw yeah
but when do you say quite poor play are
there any moves that you thought were
inaccurate
well first of all i'm supposed to play a
four if i'm giving a chance i think uh
for example in this position for example
here yeah i mean okay here
perhaps okay bishop just six better give
me six is not ever ever an idea so let's
go with one more yeah maybe here four i
mean so i i it was like very weird
because i felt like all right f4 is like
a key move for white and he was not my
f4 and i wasn't playing f4 and then he
played the fourth for 12.
what's going on okay so i like okay i
thought okay g5 is uh
should somehow be like a fortress
but i thought maybe after g5 he could
play g3
and maybe uh
so yeah like rook b3 is quite smart yeah
let's see roxy 7 here g3 with the idea
so if i uh like play in a simple way
like take stakes and let's say bishop c6
sorry uh yeah let's say king f2
and here uh we will you know whichever
rook i put on g7 uh white is in time to
play bishop e2 and bishop f3 let me just
give it a for example yeah after bishop
b2 he plays let's see
g7 i mean it's it might actually become
unclear bishop your friend here g3 yes
uh but uh yeah first of all rook takes
b7 deserves some attention here and
secondly uh he could also try maybe
something like rook h1 and then try to
improve somehow yeah because this is
like
i don't know to me it didn't look like
absolutely clear like okay perhaps it's
also like some sort of a fortress yeah
right but uh yeah probably i would not i
wouldn't be in a hurry with capturing on
f4
there was some small problem here
so let's say if i start with bishop c6
so the idea is uh after king f2 i would
probably start with rook e7 or rookie 8.
so in general i think
exchanging a pair of rooks is quite
favorable for me right uh and let's say
if he plays bishop b5 i'm always good
with like rook uh b38 so it's never an
idea for him yeah so because like yeah
i mean
invading the the b file
and here uh
let's say the difference if if i would
exchange only f4 he would have this rg1
and h5 idea which was quite quite
unpleasant i think if he's sorry i mean
let's say if we include gfgf and here he
might play let's say rook g1 so here
text takes bishop c6 here f2 g7 rg1 and
then uh h5 h5 i have with the bluetooth
g6 i i couldn't i couldn't really relate
like should you know what should i do
because i felt like maybe
i mean once once white played and the
student k4 was
quite
quite a nice move actually but and
normally you want to do this so you want
to play this move to grab some space
right yeah but uh yeah
you know but since you were solid enough
anyway
yeah i think so so
i i wasn't sure like okay in the line i
thought maybe he should take on g5 and
thinking give two and try to play like
this but um as for me i
i i don't think it's really that much
white here yeah so it's you know always
you know material is quite limited and
you know his ideas are quite limited
also so maybe i should also i could also
like stay still and like see what
you know what fight is going to do
without even g5 but i thought like all
right it's
more or less a draw and in the end it
was like funny that king g6 move
uh not actually attacking a rook yeah so
that's actually i mean okay okay so for
example if you play king of three yes i
mean okay of course they can take on h7
like english 16 g5 yes there's also sort
of yeah like and then okay i played b6
so let's say if it would be something
like a6 played probably it would be lost
for you for black but 10 okay now i have
b6 and i'm good right
and but instead of this i could also go
for something like bishop b5 to
you know to exchange
yeah to exchange not not truths but
then take considerations
i mean okay just total elimination for
for for both sides yeah i think an
obvious drill yes
yeah so well the
okay the petrol flake is very solid
opening so even like with my
uh surely not masterful touches yeah it
still still survives here did you get a
little burn from playing the night if
you decided let's come back to the
petrov
uh no i just wanted to
i just prepared against a specific line
and i was like very excited and then uh
yeah
i felt like i should need to i mean i i
i should work a little bit more night
off because i basically i didn't touch
it for okay so let's say one or two
years
this was a little bit over optimistic
yeah we have to ask you we haven't had a
chance to talk to you about this magnus
leaving tell us your thoughts
uh it's
i think it's quite bad for the
tournament first of all and uh
i think no one is happy including magnus
that you know that happened
uh but uh well as i said yesterday
probably he he has his own reasons so
i can't say if i like completely share
his opinion but uh yeah i'd say it's
i mean uh you can never be like one
hundred percent 100 percent right or 100
percent wrong so you cannot be like
completely sure
uh until like something uh
i mean until you have some direct
evidence let's say yeah yeah but uh
that's somehow the problem yeah when
when they speak about okay some some
sort of like bad things happening in
chess like fixing or whatever like or
cheating or something else i mean there
is always a problem okay you can um
without some enough evidence uh i can
come and say okay
it was a good day for me okay i was
i was lucky it reminds me as some
uh billionaire played against uh
vishyanan uh online and he crushed him
with black like after playing whatever
like d4 e5 okay it was lucky day for me
i used to play hs you know when i was
when i was a kid yeah like this yeah so
yeah you know frankly speaking uh
it's uh
it's a very big threat it's a very big
threat for chess and uh hopefully you
know everything will be all right and uh
you know uh hans will prove himself you
know innocent but uh yeah for now it's
clearly you know
i think uh the internet right now is
very hyped yellow so that's like more or
less 50 50 situation in the game i'm
getting my popcorn
well you are in the midst of it right
now actually because well magnus
not playing the rest of the term means
that you somehow eliminated a loss
does that give you better hopes for
winning the tournament
yeah you know it's probably the first
time in my career when i have to you
know made a draw and uh by by this draw
i made it to the place here
so as it was yesterday so like drawing
white and okay that's how you get into
the plus core suddenly
no but i'm not thinking about uh
about places uh of course like uh
the gaming as magnus was like very you
know very disappointing so getting like
nice position out of the opening and
then losing like this uh so
it's uh i mean it's the same feeling uh
and it doesn't really matter if like the
game counts for the overall standings or
not
uh going back to this issue that we have
in chess you've mentioned that fixing
cheating all these things have been a
problem in the past do you think that
they're ramping up do you think that we
need to take better measures against it
uh
well when we speak let's say okay after
the pandemic okay the internet uh chess
boom uh
surely uh okay this problem was
you know
became very serious and a lot of people
were you know really vocal about it
uh but uh
i don't think uh
it's anything like realistic to prevent
someone from like you know some clever
cheating
and as well as
you know the the fixing which okay
occurs i hope quite quite rarely but you
know yeah sometimes people want to get
some norms you know to share some prizes
and so on so unfortunately this also
happens hopefully not on the top level
yeah
yeah so
i think like uh it's
always you know like
uh two sides and uh
you know uh it's you know basically it's
like in the war yeah you know you the
better weapon you have okay and
your opponent also you know have to
you know
know and take some measures how to how
to counter it yes
so
i mean if if there is like a way to
avoid it like
for 100 okay probably like stop any
transmission of any games here and like
play uh you know naked in a in the
locked room yeah but uh
i'm not seeing this happening
uh do you feel it'll be difficult or
different i should say not difficult
different uh for the players playing
hands now that all of this drama has
happened and the internet is saying all
these things
but you better ask players i think yeah
so
as for me i think i'm paired with hands
in the in the last round so i think i
hope till the last round situation will
clarify yeah we hope so uh yeah thank
you for joining us here solid draw today
in the plus score janet pognacci thank
you very much john good luck with the
rest